you know you'll find me
the green machine
[Music]
our whole group has come down to
experience at eyeballs
[Music]
you got our brother from ill feed I did
seen your videos when you come in
previous almost Allah and I said look
it's the most beautiful place near our
travel all over Europe is one of most if
not the most beautiful places you in my
opinion you guys want to go for us it's
something everyone over here and me
personally I've always said they'd
rather go to a country where there are
Muslim brothers and sisters to support
them especially what in terms of the
history the recent history after the war
before what the buzz is have gone
through now you got young feed these
show making the connection in Sarajevo
you guys good two hours one that was the
short that ever talk to Sara now we got
a direct line from London to some
variable direct making it happen
fly Bosnia yeah my boy Gina's making it
happen
I was questioning thank you before you
know yeah I recognize you I do watch the
bench every now and again
[Music]
we got everybody from the UK here inside
so we got Birmingham Birmingham
Bradford's Bradford I loaded up the UK
connect sir now to said I enjoy your
show much and I keep the good
that's easy okay in the house which part
UK which London London London we got
London are here inside are evil
first time yeah first time quick picture
don't mention it
first time ever yeah first time when I'm
living absolutely I just looked at nice
to meet you as well
okay which part
another burn me do we have more so farm
trying to cut they've got for
birmingham's enough so far we counted
Manchester got London another Birmingham
[Music]
very busy you Japan a big day as well
there's a good friend of mine as well
[Music]
and we brought him here on the live
channel direct direct yes no more
connection direct as you guys know that
conversation
Shaima new minister wanna rod NEMA para
hope we both know that's basically you
guys understand so we're here we've got
to hit the bus joshiya that's the with
east meets was the main area there UK
cerebral connection
we get a lot of the words from the
Turkish side about that's Turkish right
okay Allah I'm on it and Marhaba both
Turkish so you are using
we're about to hit the cable cars up on
the top so we get a beautiful view of
the city I mean the coexistence the
Muslims in Bosnia have been historically
known for coexistence and safeguarding
the disc way coexistence was I think
entrenched in the culture of the Muslim
man here and history is full of these
stories Haggadah is one example and now
they are working on a project of
preserving that Haggadah where most of
the intellectuals people who are
influenced what's the hard work of
people I don't know
that's the religious yeah one of the one
of the oldest religious Jewish scripture
that was in fact the Sarai were
preserved between the two world wars and
the Muslim family was in charge of
preserving that the description that
they were responsible for that I mean we
are happy to really present to the world
that that Muslims never the other side
this is part of our religion part part
of Islam part of Islam and the worldview
yeah they kind of go they told the bonks
you know the coming
[Music]
that's I mean whoever reads the history
can really witness the opposite in fact
and we can go and on and on
brings the examples not too much of fox
news media exactly exactly
is it true that the Muslims were saving
the Jews at one point by putting them in
the the niqab yes traditional clothes
and also the history has has documented
such an incident and to witness that and
to support that evidence from the recent
war when enemy forces attacked Muslims
destroyed the mosques the Muslims here
they never retaliated they preserved the
churches they preserve that's what your
existence and so that's my point
no no no churches were destroyed during
no no during the genocide here against
the Muslims no no there was never
organized attack on any of other
religious group or any other ethnic
groups and that was thanks to our
heritage
thanks thanks to Islam yeah part of the
parcel of the culture and the world this
is amazing so you had the sanctity of
churches during the greatest Jonas this
was the greatest genocide after World
War two and I think everybody should
come here visits Ruben itza visit the
history that we think the the the recent
history just to take the lessons and the
world can learn from the experience of
the of the recent history in in Bosnia
how in fact you come up with the
positive response to such horrific
events that took place at the time you
said it takes you harder before we go on
yeah pity make sure
[Laughter]
[Music]
nothing worthy of worship except Allah
to created the heavens and earth and
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
is the last in front of us were sent to
mankind let's do it
back at the UK connection here
this beautiful view up here let's check
it out representing the pure monotheism
ideas only Jeremy can London Luton
London London originally from Oldham but
I've been for the last 25 years in in
London we got the UK survival connection
aqua Diablo huh mashallah bismillah
[Music]
theme park in the UK that has cable cars
running from one end of the park to do
the talk way through halfway through
stopped at the highest point and the
wrong technical problem half an hour my
kids oh my kids
[Music]
I also point out before I don't end up
yeah
undiscovered gem in the heart of Europe
in the next two days through the
different groups and tours you will take
you will have a opportunity to
experience different natural attractions
different historical attractions towards
ccd history everything that they are
really enjoying a new destination
creation from one brother looks like
Jesus here he looks like Jesus see Jesus
had you know he's not like - portrayed
and you know many of those white white
skin blue eyes
he was darker complexion wavy hair he
fit the description and he's Muslim one
who submits to the will of God that's
what Jesus did come to the lot are you
doing it
[Music]
oh you like it how you join senator were
you from China okay maybe soon huh yeah
yeah you can learn more thank you
hi
[Music]
you know what that mean when we say
something that means peace be with you
I mean peace be with you good learning
opportunity every hotel should have a
prayer right you agree and if you're
gonna pray you don't wanna pray to a
human being to materialism to your toe
statue to icon till I don't I'm afraid
to the one who created you
in Arabic Allah the English God Almighty
the Creator Allah the one and only
they resistible the most loving the most
kind